joining me now is Molly Hemingway
editor-in-chief of the Federalist Fox
News contributor and Chris Bedford
executive editor of the Common Sense
Society Molly what's most important for
both Front Runners at this point let's
start with President Trump yeah I like
the advice that you gave I think
president Trump has the advantage of
having so many Republican voters who
don't just like him they love him they
love the policies that he did when he
was president but they are genuinely
concerned about whether or not he can
win and he needs to make that case that
he can win he should talk about the
Coalition that he's building why he has
the ability to put together the best
Coalition what his successes were during
his first term as president and you know
just really addressed that issue that
concerned that many Republicans have and
as and as for Ron DeSantis I think you
know he needs to also follow your advice
there of not listening to the swamp
voices about what he should do but
really trusting his gut understanding
that he should not be trying to distance
himself so much from president Trump
because of how much Republican voters do
like those Trump policies well and Chris
to Molly's point then I'm going to get
to a statement Trump made today but to
Molly's point on DeSantis I didn't see
the entire interview but I do know that
he when he talked about Putin today he
said yeah I think he is guilty of war
crimes and you know I I'm not saying
that's a bad thing to say at all but it
does kind of begin to shift him over
toward the GOP establishment
um especially given what XI and Putin
just pulled off with their their meeting
and a new meeting scheduled uh in
Beijing uh your thoughts on the Ukraine
angle which I did not address tonight
well it's unless you can explain the
difference between somebody committing
war crimes and the just interests of the
United States of course it's just for
the United States to try and stop war
crimes but is it always in U.S interest
when you're courting world war three
that's something that should be
seriously considered it's something
that's not at all been considered here
in Washington DC and some of the people
like to santis and a lot of Americans
are actually wondering so you don't have
to actually say Vladimir Putin's a good
guy you can sit back and say obviously
this is a bad man but is it in the
American interest to take boys from Iowa
and girls from New Jersey and to get
them potentially embroiled in a massive
and escalating war in Ukraine because
that is the kind of danger they're
traveling they're playing with here and
to send us I think at least so far has
done a good job of threading that needle
and Molly I want to get your reaction to
the statement president Trump released
today criticizing DeSantis it gets to
something I hit on in the angle he said
he is for a republican an average
Governor Ron was a big lockdown Governor
other Republican Governors did much
better than Ron and because I allowed
them this Freedom never close their
states
um Molly do you think anyone in America
thinks lockdowns when they hear Ron
DeSantis
not very many people would think that
because even while he did have some
shutdowns early on in the covid pandemic
response he was kind of known for
resisting that and he had so much
success it's one of his things that he's
probably if he runs he will be running
touting his great success and how he
handled the response to the coveted
pandemic much better than other
Governors did and that's just another
thing I want to say Ron DeSantis should
focus on what a good Governor he is and
how he's shown such leadership and how
other Republican Governors should be but
you know he should not backtrack he had
some good statements on the Ukraine war
that matched with what the average
Republican voter and even average
American really thinks about the Biden
McConnell foreign policy that we are
being subjected to right now when he
kind of catered to that Beltway
establishment swamp mindset I think that
worries a lot of people that we he won't
have the courage of his convictions to
stay strong I mean it was he's been
pretty nuanced in both way so we'll see
how it goes but he he does need to show
courage Under Fire from how the Beltway
establishment is going to react to him
not adopting the failed foreign policy
that they have been pushing for decades
now and Chris look Trump has the
experience with obviously these foreign
leaders he knows what it's like to face
down NATO tell him to stand up spend
more money at their military even though
he got huge pushback from The Usual
Suspects in the media and politics back
home now DeSantis doesn't have that
experience doesn't mean he can't be
great at it but Trump has the advantage
in my mind on the geopolitical stage
with XI dealing with them and certainly
the Europeans given how things seem to
be declining in much of the West today
yes despite the shrill cries from other
networks or from the Washington Post
that Donald Trump was always being
laughed at by Europeans they did exactly
what he asked him to do he was
essentially a giant when he bestowed the
world stage he he walked with the power
of the United States and people listened
he was dining across from Xi Jinping
when he had missiles launched a launched
a uh Syria that's something but that's
something I think Ron DeSantis has been
trying to hit on too because Donald
Trump's foreign policy was consistently
undermined and his phone calls leaked by
his Generals in Afghanistan and by the
National Security Council this happened
over and over again and the Santa has
made the point that Personnel is
something that he takes very seriously
that this is something he surrounded
himself with very loyal people in his
government he hasn't had those leaks and
a lot of the Personnel problems that
Donald Trump suffered from have gotten
significantly worse after he left office
there's a still a good amount of slime
and grift around around the former
president but this still he's got that
great Advantage if you go to Iowa where
the Santa and Donald Trump would have
been in the last two weeks the sentence
is still only drawing a couple people
which is a lot more than anyone else
except for Donald Trump everywhere he
goes thousands and thousands of people
still show up there are still lines out
front because the GOP is so stupid
generally the professional class these
are the only two candidates who are
running in the popular slain so it's
going to be up to them to try and figure
out who's going to be the who's going to
be the nominee Donald Trump's got the
excitement but descendants I think does
have a better team uh Molly and Chris
great to see both of you hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else